Wow really
no what happened is hair well what is
that tempted doing that that's [ __ ]
come anyway how's it going right welcome
back ship what's he doing okay what
happens but what is he doing being stuck
indoors it's nothing funny man nothing
funny like a my reindeer nose thank you
step aside woman probably licking YUM
nothing's nothing all right grinding
nail debt alright so we're gonna start a
new quest today as always this game is
just full of weird and crazy surprises
so I'm become cured yes of course what
do you need help with I don't know fire
cracking at a toilet alright sure that's
it girls are just like I don't know what
to say I didn't say anything okay so
this should be good a classic prank
breast Hey plant the Firecracker ten
twenty odd yeah that was funny right
wasn't it school sword what is it ooh so
cool alright I'm buying this only
because my other one was just so stupid
so now I look cool and stuff yeah what
that where you got to go upstairs for
this one it's in the chemistry room I
don't know why I know this is no biology
weedkiller what oh yeah he looks like a
dragon
hello yeah boy don't just stand there
come and help what do you want sir why
did you send for me why did he do that
strange for Eva oh yes I did
uh-huh look at that plant
boy that is a [ __ ] magnificent isn't
it I guess you could say that
yes EULA magnascribe 40 Simha okay a
rare and precious Venus flytrap okay
thank you unfortunately there is a boy
at this school
Darby Harrington who was given such a
plant from his father his father is not
a nice man Darby is not a nice boy and
how this concerned me and to belittle my
collection there are two sides to
biology boy tell me all about ieave and
yeah yes that makes sense that to kill
them myself to the year very clear sir
you want me to kill Darby Harrington now
KITT right on and why would a teacher
send me out to do this get a haircut
from the salon why why what does that
have to do with killing a plant I'll
never understand alright let's go
stop Christmas tree alright [ __ ] I
forgot they don't speak all right we're
gonna get Vesper actually I miss her I
think she's over here
hi Robert I don't want no one picked
this up yeah it doesn't make sense I
mean there's a rubber band it's
beautiful you need wrap well it's not
can [ __ ] this up well right tendon pops
hey handsome let's make out hi there
welcome now get to the lovin and she's
watching - it's a big ol orgy why
what is she we're looking at good for
you I don't even know why I did that I
feel disgusting now all right so this
one Vespa I Love You Man Oh beautiful
step aside [ __ ] [ __ ] that was [ __ ]
epic I make out with a girl and then I'd
ride on my best bud puncher all right I
love this game all right we're going
over there
it's pretty close
[ __ ] the cops are after me [ __ ] off cops
I need to get a haircut and you can't
stop me oh yeah whoa back flip of
vengeance hey what hey what's a bow it's
just kind of get a haircut Oh what the
[ __ ] Matt good boy
chestnut goodbye chocolate they're all
good boy haircuts that's kinda like me
[ __ ] all right let's get this one fine
all right we got our hair cut and now we
shall roll the streets where's the bad
spot oh thank god
now we need to go back to school all
right
[Music]
oh yeah best first and everything no no
no no no no [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] just to say
get in there all right good
I never been in here and talk to bed
well if it isn't one that sounds like a
beat defend yourself you're so you're so
lame ass dumb ass [ __ ] you suck
what's your problem your mama gave birth
to you I get it
I got a slingshot though bamm-bamm
nipple shot come on come on give me your
best shot
come on you need your nanny for what let
me kick Carrie
alright man brofist bruffett stay
awesome Mack and favorite I'm just
kidding alright let's go in front I'm
probably gonna have to kill these two
this thing shot is really good if you
charge it they die I'm two shots what is
this
Oh eggs I love me some eggs we got to go
upstairs breasts another funky music
it's like in the ride back to the
eighties or examine how about friends
they don't even carry high now I was
still got to go upstairs this is a
[ __ ] big house man
what is he doing you can't touch this
Ben and Anna Dana Dana can't touch Pitts
soon yeah I can't go into going go in
the [ __ ] the way thank you Jesus all
right we need to kill him I mean the
plant oh okay
they have a toxic material right next to
it how can they get right suck it [ __ ]
it's not doing that much show isn't this
dangerous there we go
all right hey des how'd the Sun right
next to poor plaid man this plan scares
the [ __ ] out of me
don't use my my girlfriend love these
type of plans I hate them I'm not
bringing them in my house I don't have a
house but I'm not if I ever have one I
was
it's how I danced at the club so we get
all the latest what you think you can
that's better than that but prove it
what's what's the task get out of a
Harrison house all right
the digital dare today - dude do they
only did it I'm down to Dover DE home
today I'm reporter pom-pom for down for
town but I'm okay I just punch the
[ __ ] door open that's a bit bro tough
I don't know I never actually punched a
door open hello how's it going wow what
the [ __ ] you think you're doing opening
doors where I'm staying [ __ ] alright
[ __ ] tar shun I don't even give a
[ __ ] I should just take one of the
spears and kill people
alright I think we did it good job bro
and I do that smoky fake smoke
alright forgot to do my dad's [ __ ] whoa
I get a lot of money now the penetration
how's it going friends okay I've got
that's guys all right the scan is
started now the quest I guess there's
one in school and there's one in town
which one should we pick then one at
school okay I heard you think okay
good thinking because we're close to
school you are smarter than you are
you're like not saying that you don't
look smart you look really smart how do
I see you oh I'm always watching that's
PI do something how am i safe in here
I am cool let me do a we should sleep I
think that's what we should do and
another day dawns and I have my
Christmas is here I get a Christmas
present
yeah why oh my god best spy here that's
the best present I could ever get though
it's at fireworks
what are you doing boom headshot Wow
stop that wasn't me I swear it was Vespa
grinding on the rafts BAM perfect
naylet so good at this game
alright upstairs and we get shut up not
helping anyone helping nobody yes what's
going on ago what is my present yeah I
was right in front of you okay you may
go now okay
oh I don't want to wear this why did I
even take this stupid class boy are you
laughing at it from my mama [ __ ] you
will for Suffolk for this climb say my
sweater is beautiful and I consider it
say it say it we are appalled saying
sorry okay let's focus on what we were
doing we were taking the quest in town
because now that it's Christmas I can't
take the quest in school anymore so
don't look at me like that
right it's best about
she should be here hey what my beautiful
that cop is [ __ ] crazy I don't even
care
[ __ ] the police what am i doing
he's waiting for me it's champing it's
not fair
oh I lost my anyway cool alright let's
see if I can finish this or start this
quest rather whoa I beg you say that
like it's Santa Claus yes of course
Santa Claus what's gonna give hobo some
change
why not that's the Christmas you know i
unlock the black a cowboy hat I need to
go in here right here it is hello
potential homosexual nothing wrong with
being that nothing at home thanks I
might check it out alright there's a
meeting for nerds of course you can't
you guys having fun you can't join our
party I'm sorry what is he doing he's
dancing stop dancing
there's no music I can always use this
place to crash so this is my new hub
beef patties consumers high score of
1,000 lb what what hell is this what
left altar side I increase health avoid
at all costs bounces you right
get your oh [ __ ] I'm at 200 no way I can
beat this no well it wasn't really a
surprise I'm not really good why why why
did you lost your appetite
why that's perfect but that's the only
quest you serious no I'm not I'm not
doing that stupid [ __ ] no I'm not get
back to the nerd hangout no I'm not I
started this one Bulevar failed bike
ride I got my bets pop hell yeah [ __ ]
no way you should win this one
BAM oh [ __ ] they're actually kind of
fast
nurse
the only bad thing about vests
physically I get stuck I guess but why
am i second place when I'm clearly first
it's not really that fair you know they
are riding bicycles and I'm riding a vet
spot been hey I'll take it
I'm still winning that no I'm second
place what the hell they each took a
shortcut you chain ten [ __ ] come
back let me kill you I'm gonna kill you
don't think I won't do it
best face out of control [ __ ]
whoa back [ __ ]
[Laughter]
put your hands down for me brauch bad
ass with that sweater I love that
sweater I want it now that's done I got
a bike helmet now and the bike Jason
finally I get a helmet good
it's you and me Vespa I [ __ ] love you
honestly it doesn't look like I can do
that much else today unless I do that
[ __ ] that other thing and I don't
really want to do that one so I'm just
gonna go and save now on this thing
alright so that was it for today hope
you bros enjoyed this episode
lucky favours you did subscribe come to
earth today and I'll see you like hobby
breath say awesome
I know friend let's go I will sing to
you
let it be let it be